hi there Steve Kaufman here today it's
the 30th of December 2019 it's near the
end of the year and we start a new
decade so it's a good time to sort of
take stock I think at the end of the
year is always the time people think
about you know what do I want to do next
year when Diet Eve this year personal
relationships personal development work
and so forth
so if we think of language learning is
so which is what I always talk about
here you know why do we learn languages
you know what is the purpose and I think
if we understand the purpose of language
learning I think that can influence how
we learn how we teach how we treat other
people who are learning or speaking
other languages if we understand what
the fundamental purpose of language
learning is and to me the fundamental
purpose of language learning is to enjoy
the language
I mean language gives us so much
enjoyment that's true even of our own
language through language we can
communicate with you know friends and
family we can enjoy books we can enjoy
movies we can enjoy the language itself
we can enjoy the things that we learned
through the language or that we hear
about through the language it's all
about enjoyment and so let me teach the
language and I always get back to
capital on this great Hungarian polyglot
she lived in the mostly in the 20th
century who had this formula so success
in language learning depends on our
attitude times the amount of time we
spend with the language divided by
inhibition and I add to that frustration
everything that's negative so attitude
obviously if we are teaching the
language the most important thing has to
be to create a positive attitude in the
learner so that the learner enjoys it
like in school
for example and somehow to get the
learner to spend time with the language
and to reduce everything that causes
inhibition frustration negative feelings
so then the question is why have tests
what's the purpose of tests in school
because I know many people countless
people English speakers in Canada who go
through the school system learning
French every day passing their tests and
never ever used the language never use
French not interested in French don't
read in French don't want fresh movies
other than with subtitles don't get into
everything all the enjoyment of the
language can bring you so why do we
teach in this way the number if I were
teaching school number one goal is how
do I get the learner to enjoy this
language or any language how do I get
the learner to get into the enjoyment of
language that has to be the number one
goal and if we assess our own activity
in language learning am i enjoying it am
i enjoying the language and enjoyment
can come in many different ways like
I've been learning Persian I speak it
extremely poorly and as a result I am
NOT interested in things Persian so I
read a book in English about a girl
growing up in Iran is called Arya and
there's various reviews suggest that
there's a lot of inaccuracies but it's
still it's an involvement with your
honor like came to me because I'm
learning Persian languages bring us
enjoyment that enjoyment to me is more
important than whether I nail the
grammar correctly so if enjoyment is and
it's very important to this that because
I spend a lot of time learning languages
going a bit crazy right now with my
Persian Arabic and Turkish but it's very
important that I am convinced and that's
true for any member that what I am doing
is worthwhile that the time that I spend
is time well spent this is good this is
bringing the enjoyment it'll bring me
probably some you know improvement in I
agree
but it's it's worth doing it's it's it's
bringing me rewarding things so it's
important that the in order to get
people to spend the time remember
catalogs formula altitude time /
inhibition we have to spend the time so
we have to feel at that time is well
spent
worthwhile enjoyable so similarly when
we comment on others who speak a
language and here I you know I had a
video there where I said that you get
negative comments I get negative
comments and Christine who put up this
wonderful video where she speaks many
languages get some negative comments and
why well some people commented well you
know she speaks so many languages and
Matt says that it takes three to five
years to become good in a language what
does that mean what is good in a
language mean you know if I can
understand if I can communicate with
errors I'm good okay I may not be a
native I may not even be near a native
but if I can understand what people are
saying and they can understand me I'm
good or good enough and it's not for us
to comment on other people's ability
that is meaningless we learned languages
for ourselves because we think it's
enjoyable to learn languages and when we
start Christine's video it's obvious
that she enjoys those languages and some
people commented well you know she
obviously stopped between each language
and you know she didn't get into great
depth and so maybe she doesn't know them
like thank you these people know nothing
about her level of skill in these
languages it's absolutely meaningless to
make these kinds of comments based on
this one video rather the video is a
celebration of different languages that
she obviously enjoys and so you know if
something want to pursue absolute
perfection which I consider to be
elusive in a language that's fine if
other people want to have less than
perfection in a number of languages
that's equally fine
because whatever it is we set our own
goals in the language and the ultimate
sort of underlying goal always is
enjoyment and you know of all the people
that I have interacted with in English
who are not native speakers where we've
had a wonderful relationship friends or
business relationships and they're
speaking English less than perfectly
it's good we're communicating they're
enjoying the language they're enjoying
the ability to communicate in what is to
them a foreign language just as I enjoy
the ability to communicate in what is to
me a foreign language whether that be
Russian Chinese Japanese French Spanish
whatever and I'm well aware that I have
limitations in all of those languages
but they gave me a great sense of
enjoyment and so I think it's very
important you know as we come to the end
of the year we're gonna create maybe
some you know New Year's resolutions and
what we want to do it and if if language
learning is part of what we like to do
then I would say make sure your language
learning is grounded in your enjoyment
of the language or languages that you
are learning and don't criticize and
particularly don't correct other people
unless they ask you to do so and even
then I wouldn't do often and if people
are involved in teaching I think if you
can ignite the fire of interest and
enjoyment in in language learning and
forget all the testing of grammar
because all those things kick in only
very very slowly but if you can get
people motivated and they realize what a
rich world language learning brings them
that that would be job well done so I
wish everyone a Happy New Year enjoy
your life returning you learn to my
everyone enjoy the process I will see
you in the new year
bye for now